y un isótopo contiene 16 protones 18
electrones y 16 neutrones cuál es la
identidad del isótopo los invito a que
pause en el vídeo para que lo intente y
les daré una pista tal vez quieran usar
esta tabla periódica ok suponiendo que
ya lo intentaron vamos a ver un elemento
se define por el número de protones que
contiene así que si alguien les dice el
número de protones ustedes podrán saber
analizando la tabla periódica cuál es el
elemento del que les están hablando
entonces si en este caso el isótopo
tiene 16 protones cuál es el número
atómico del elemento que tiene 16
protones bueno por definición si algo
tiene 16 protones estamos hablando de
azufre entonces vamos a escribir una s
grande ok y ahora lo siguiente en lo que
necesitamos pensar es en el número
mágico o también llamado número de masa
d
isótopo en particular porque recuerden
que un isótopo bueno todos los átomos de
azufre tienen 16 protones pero pueden
tener diferente número de neutrones
entonces los azufres que tienen
diferente número de neutrones serán
diferentes isótopos y en este caso
tenemos 16 protones y 16 neutrones y si
sumamos los protones y neutrones tenemos
16 más 16 y eso es igual a 32 y ahora
vamos a ver si hay alguna carga bueno
los protones tienen una carga positiva y
los electrones tienen una carga negativa
y si tenemos la misma cantidad de
protones y de electrones entonces no
habrá ninguna carga pero en este caso
tenemos 2 electrones más entonces si
tenemos más partículas cargadas
negativamente como en este caso que
tenemos 2 más entonces vamos a tener una
carga negativa 2 que se escribe como
- así que este es un jot
tiene una carga entonces este es el
isótopo de azufre que tiene un número de
masa de 32 porque la suma de protones y
neutrones da 32 y tiene 2 electrones
extras a comparación del número de
protones lo que le da esta carga
negativa ok
hagamos otro ejemplo pero ahora nos
están dando esta información sobre el
isótopo y bueno este también es un ión
porque tiene esta carga negativa así que
ahora tenemos que deducir cuál es el
número de protones electrones y
neutrones bueno lo primero que les puedo
decir es que mil nos dicen que este es
flúor y si sabemos con qué elemento
estamos trabajando al analizar la tabla
periódica podemos conocer el número
atómico y así podemos calcular el número
de protones porque recuerden que el
número atómico es el número de protones
y eso es lo que define al elemento
eso es lo que hace que este elemento sea
flor entonces veamos la tabla periódica
aquí está el flúor es el número atómico
9 eso significa que cualquier flúor
tiene 9 protones entonces solo porque es
flúor ya sabemos que tiene 9 protones y
qué más podemos deducir bueno sabemos
que tenemos una carga negativa aquí
esta es una carga 1 negativa y eso
significa que tenemos un electrón extra
a comparación del número de protones por
lo tanto como tenemos 9 protones en este
caso tenemos 10 electrones y finalmente
cuántos neutrones tenemos bueno
recuerden que la suma de protones y
neutrones es lo que nos da el número de
masa entonces si tenemos 9 protones
cuántos neutrones necesitamos para que
nos dé 18 claro tenemos 9 neutrones
porque 99 es igual a 18